we are told a rectangle has a height of
five and a width of three x squared
minus x plus two
and then we're told express the area of
the entire rectangle and the expression
should be expanded so pause this video
and and see if you can work through this
all right now let's work through this
together and what this diagram is
showing us is exactly an indicative
rectangle where its height is 5
and its width is three x squared minus x
plus two and what this shows us is as
the area of the entire rectangle can be
broken down into three smaller areas you
have this blue area right over here
where the width is 3x squared the height
is 5. so what's that area going to be
well it's going to be the height times
width 5 times 3x squared and that's the
same thing as 15x squared
now what about this purple area
right over here well it's going to be
height times width again so it'll be 5
times negative x which is the same thing
as negative 5x and i know what some of
you are thinking how can you have a
width of negative x
well we don't know what x is so this is
all a little bit abstract but you could
imagine having x be a negative value in
which case this actually would be a
positive width another thing you might
be saying is hey this magenta area when
i just eyeball it looks like it has a
larger width than this blue area how do
we know that we don't they're just
showing this as an indicative way
they might have actually the same width
they might have one might be larger than
the other but this is just showing us
that they're not necessarily the same
it's very abstract it's definitely not
drawn to scale because we don't know
what x is
all right and then this last area is
going to be the height which is 5 times
the width which is 2 so that's just
going to be equal to 10. so what we just
saw is that the area of the whole thing
is equal to the sum of these areas and
the sum of those areas is
15
x squared
plus negative 5x we could just write
that as minus 5x
and then we have plus 10. now i know
what some of you are thinking if i know
that the height is 5 and the width is
this value well couldn't i have just
multiplied height times the entire width
3x squared minus x plus 2 and then i
would have just naturally distributed
the 5. and essentially that's exactly
what we did here area models you might
have first seen them in elementary
school really to understand the
distributive property and so if you
distribute the 5 you get 15 x squared
minus 5x plus 10. same idea let's do
another example
so here we're given another rectangle
has a height of 2x we see that right
there a width of 3x plus 4. we see that
over there express the area of the
entire rectangle so same drill
see if you can pause this video and work
on this on your own
all right well we can see that the
height is 2x the width in total is 3x
plus 4
but we can clearly see that the area of
the entire thing can be broken up into
this blue section in this magenta
section the blue section's area is 3x
times 2x so 3x times 2x which is equal
to 6x squared and the magenta section is
equal to width times height its area so
that's going to be equal to 8x and so
the area of the whole thing is going to
be the sum of these areas which is going
to be 6x squared plus 8x and we're done
and once again we could have just
thought about it as the height is 2x
we're going to multiply it times the
width times 3x plus 4 and then we just
distribute the 2x so 2x times 3x is 6x
squared 2x times 4 is 8x same idea it's
really just to make sure we understand
that when we distribute a 2x onto this
3x and this 4 we can conceptualize it as
figuring out the areas of the sub parts
of the entire rectangle